we want to remember a legend and a
friend dr. Charles Krauthammer who
passed away yesterday at the age of 68
after a battle with cancer the biggest
error that we make is to lose the damn
war because we refuse to recognize who
the enemy is and what it requires for
God's sake why do you have to talk about
that the mourning is over the Shiva is
done and if you're a you know if you're
a conservative you should be optimistic
I think it'll you know it'll snow in
hell before the DOJ is gonna go after
her we all were expecting it didn't
happen that was a dog that didn't bark
Charles was the leading conservative
thinker of his generation
too many he touched so many of our lives
right here at the Fox News Channel I
gotta tell you I often found myself on
the opposite end of the opinion fence
from Charles Krauthammer that was the
case for just about a decade on special
report
Charles was also like me a huge baseball
fan and last night Charles was honored
at Nationals Park in DC so you know you
know we're people outside of Fox asked
me about Charles I think it's very hard
sometimes to explain to them how he
touched so many of us because they think
oh how could all you guys know but Jesse
had a very special relationship Jesse
explained well I was a producer for the
O'Reilly factor for many years and it
was my great honour to produce Charles
Krauthammer for about five of those
years so once a week I would get on the
phone with dr. Krauthammer and I would
transcribe his talking points about
bills topics for that night and then I
would absorb the talking points and I
would go to the bar later and repeat
them as if they were I love doing it and
I also remember for years I would DVR
special report and then I would
fast-forward to the all-star panel at
the end fast-forward through you know
and I would just listen at rows and what
the difference with Charles compared to
any other commentator when he spoke
everything went quiet and you listened
and you never interrupted Charles not
even O'Reilly interrupted Charles and
that's a pretty tall order even my
mother like the Charles Krauthammer
because he had a way about him he was so
rational and so respectful he was never
disagreeable and you could always kind
of as a liberal disagree with him but
not hate him and he was never ever
attacked
if you ever realized from the left and
it shows the kind of the depth of his
power because he was honored by george w
bush the Nationals Benjamin Netanyahu I
had friends texting me randomly I'm so
sorry to hear about Charles he really
had such a great impact I remember the
first time I met him face to face I was
in the DC bureau and I just come back
from one of those crazy waters worlds
and I was all cocky and I rolled into
the green room and Charles in that kind
of low tone says Jesse thank you so much
for allowing me to be in your world so
Kennedy we were in the green room and
you said something about what Charles
meant to you that really caught me by
surprise I was I was taken by it was
wonderful there's something so
incredibly positive about what he did
which was he opened a window of mourning
and let people in on the knowledge that
he did not have long left in this world
and there's something so sweet and
honorable honorable about that because
if you think about it the only time we
really talk about people in these
glowing terms is after they pass but if
you actually allow someone into the end
of your life so they can celebrate you
and let you know what you've meant to
them while you're still living that is
so incredibly profound and it is such an
amazing gift that very few people are
capable of giving so many people and he
was able to do that he had the
confidence and he had enough respect for
himself
his audience and his very close friends
and colleagues here at Fox and I think
we will be forever grateful for that not
only for so many people having the
opportunity to reach out to him but also
as an example to other people that you
can take this on with a degree of
positivity and comportment that we
rarely see and I hope people see that as
an example and they're not ashamed of
passing
to the next room because you know as
people of faith and there are a lot of
people of faith here we embrace the
afterlife but we're terrified of dying
and and there was such bravery and
strength that Charles Charles showed
going into that you know I always
thought and the reason your words
touched me is that I always thought the
idea that someone who was paralyzed and
living in a wheelchair for him to do
just what we do to come and be
commentators on television to write a
column boy he was terrific about it he
never was self pitying yes yeah no I
mean that's he had to face something
every day that was beyond his own
disability it was people that he met
that weren't aware that he was disabled
until they met him and because he always
he when he was shot at Fox you know you
you wait you couldn't tell that he was
in a wheelchair and it was I think that
was his choice because he didn't want to
be he didn't want that as any kind of
interference and so when you meet him
maybe you didn't know and I remember
what am I one of my buddies made a joke
about should Charles go on Dancing with
the Stars and I said you were such an
a-hole and he had no idea he's a huge
fan of Charlie was after Tucker was on
he had no idea that Charles Krauthammer
was in a wheelchair we you know he's a
he's a very serious dude he's very funny
but the one thing that was interesting
about him is that he never let this
whatever happened to him in his life
actually affect him in a weird way it
turned into an asset for him because it
made him a man of ideas because he was
limited in what he was he was in a chair
for his entire life and he made his
achievement come from here everything
was about ideas and the other thing I
would just mention is that we do live in
a time when more people are healthy and
they live longer there's less disease
there's less poverty but we have this we
have an increase in suicides we see
people that are dealing with inner
demons and I think that's why he is so
inspirational is because he has every
excuse to hate life every excuse does he
did the opposite he embraced it I don't
think I could be that man I honestly do
not think I could be 10% of Charles
Krauthammer
eight
that's that's the definition of courage
I think it yes when people stand up in
the midst of dire circumstances Candice
what you think I exactly agree with
everything that you guys said here
despite his disability he will be
remembered as a man of great fortitude
you know his character his strength his
virtue people from both sides of the
political aisle coming together and
honoring this man shows you that he was
a person of tremendous character and
look he he was happy with his life
and I think that that's the most
wonderful thing the wonderful takeaway
here is how happy and content he was
with the life that he lived well you
know it's a interesting for me because I
knew him for so long I knew him before
Fox even and I'd say two things about
Charles one is that the sense of spirit
and human kindness that came from
Charles Krauthammer was no pretense
you know you'd introduced him to people
at Fox and they would be like Oh Charles
Krauthammer and he would be like
cracking jokes and open with so many
folks just very warm and by the way
Jessie going to a baseball game with
Charles was literally people coming up
to him because he gave structure to so
much conservative thought a lot of
conservatives felt
hey this is the guy this is the
intellectual that is able to frame
conservative thought in such a way that
the Liberals and the left has trouble
with it that they finally feel that here
is an intellectual of the right some
people call the neoconservatives but it
was Charles who talked about the Reagan
doctrine in terms of America globally
standing up for freedom for security he
talked about a bush doctor in terms of
going into war he gave the framework and
going to baseball Jessie with him not
only did you see that people were
thinking conservative thinking and for
doing that but you learned that the
learners who own the Washington
Nationals love Charles so here we are
you know you go in Charles's specially
made band going down South Capitol
Street and here we are you I want you to
take a look at that picture again that's
Charles on the big screen over the
stadium last night as the Nats were
playing the Orioles and there was a
moment of silence hmm but if you drove
that and you and you think oh my god is
this guy gonna crash this thing but you
get to Nationals Park and he had the
best parking spot just because the
learners had a parking spot for him in
the stadium and I was like
how come I can't get this thing Jesse
not wants to fight by that actually get
a van and I know a few people that have
driven with Charles and they it was
probably one of the most and frightening
things wait wait wait Charles is driving
he drives I don't think people are aware
of that like when you're saying a van
the assumption is that maybe somebody is
driving oh he's driving it then yes
especially equipped man and then I used
to joke I've seen just before that you
know the most expensive car in the Fox
parking lot didn't belong to Brett or
Brett hill or me buddy you you really
think it was a man a personification of
courage yes
and and what an incredible example and I
do hope that in addition to some of the
writing and the philosophy that he
imbued in his writing people also take
away the incredible lesson at the end of
his life and internalize that for their
own in the future
that's so sweet thank you Karen